we're told glenn drained the water from
his baby's bathtub the graph below shows
the relationship between the amount of
water left in the tub in liters and how
much time had passed in minutes since
glenn started draining the tub and then
they ask us a few questions
how much water was in the tub when glenn
started draining how much water drains
every minute every two minutes how long
does it take for the tub to drain
completely pause this video and see if
you can answer any or all of these
questions based on this graph right over
here
all right now let's do it together let's
start with this first question how much
water was in the tub when glenn started
draining so what we see here is when
we're talking about when glenn started
draining that would be at time t equals
zero so time t equals zero is right over
here and then so how much water is in
the tub it's right over there
and this point when you're looking at a
graph often has a special label if you
view this as the y-axis the vertical
axis is the y-axis and the horizontal
axis is the x-axis although when you're
measuring time sometimes people will
call it the t-axis but for the sake of
this video let's call this the x-axis
this point at which you intersect the
y-axis that tells you what is y when x
is zero or what is the water in the tub
when time is zero so this tells you the
y-intercept here tells you how much in
this case
how much
water we started off with in the tub and
we can see it's 15 liters
if i'm reading that graph correctly
how much water drains every minute every
two minutes pause this video how would
you think about that
all right so they're really asking about
a rate what's the rate at which water's
draining every minute so let's see if we
can find two points on this graph that
look pretty clear so right over there at
time one minute looks like there's 12
liters in it
and in the tub and then at time two
minutes there's nine liters so it looks
like
as
one minute passes so we go plus one
minute
plus one minute what happens to the
water in the tub
well it looks like the water in the tub
goes down by went from 12 liters to 9
liters so negative 3
liters
and this is a line so that should keep
happening so if we forward another plus
1 minute we should go down another three
liters and that is exactly what is
happening so it looks like the tub is
draining three liters per minute so
draining
draining
three
liters
per
minute and so if they say every two
minutes well if you're doing three
liters per every one minute then you're
going to do twice as much every two
minutes so six
liters
every
two minutes
two
minutes
but all of this the second question we
were able to answer by looking at the
slope so in this context y-intercept to
help us figure out well where did we
start off the slope is telling us the
rate at which the water in this case is
changing
and then they ask us how long does it
take for the tub to drain completely
pause this video and see if you can
answer that
well the situation which the tub has
drained completely that means that
there's no water left in the tub so that
means that our y value our water value
is down at zero and that happens on the
graph right over there
and this point
where we the graph intersects the x-axis
that's known as the x-intercept
and in this context it says hey at what
x-value do we not have any of the y
value left is there the water has run
out and we see that happens at an x
value of five and but that's giving us
the time in minutes so that happens at
five minutes
after five minutes
all of the water is drained and that
makes a lot of sense
if you have 15 liters and you're
draining three liters every minute it
makes sense that it takes five minutes
to drain all 15 liters